um
I can't hard trouble reading this
Reuters uh the tangent about both
hey what's going on everybody I'm not
reading this I'm Dave Rubin this is the
Reuben report we are live from the swamp
that's right we are in Washington DC I'm
doing a whole slew of interviews with
senators and Congress people I'm making
a couple other TV appearances I was on
Tim Poole's podcast last night I'll be
heading over to the Newsmax Studios a
little bit later lots going on here in
DC it's kind of funny when we set up
this trip obviously the idea was this
was sort of going to be a Victory
celebration because this Red Wave was
anticipated we certainly did not get the
red wave and there's some more evidence
of that coming out of Arizona just in
the last 12 hours or so however it does
look like Republicans will at least get
the house which at this point leads to
still somewhat of a lame duck situation
for the Democrats they won't be able to
push that much through regardless what
happens with the Senate uh and they have
been uh I've been talking about that
with Jim Jordan yesterday a senator Rand
Paul this morning Ted Cruz is coming by
a little bit later and we're going to be
posting these interviews over the next
couple days and I sense really uh just
from the two interviews I've done so far
with Congressman Jim Jordan and from
Rand Paul is that there is sort of this
renewed like oh we maybe have to do a
little bit better than being just the
anti-democrat party we have to sort of
model this thing a little bit more like
what's going on in Florida like there
are ways to win this thing and maybe
some of us drop the ball to some degree
or The Wider Republican party did or
whatever it might be so anyway today
we're going to be sort of catching you
up on everything that's happened in the
last week a little bit about big Tech
and censorship and a little more of the
lunacy from the left and all that good
stuff and then this afternoon we are
just going to wander around the mall we
are going to wander around DC I was
thinking maybe I would put on a little
lipstick and a dress and see if I could
get an interview with the president so
uh we're gonna have to find what size
what size would I be in a nice sundress
do you think I guess that would be a
large right probably for a woman I would
be a woman's large but Daphne said I can
borrow her lipstick so it's all very
exciting around here uh and before we
get to it let's talk about Bonner
private wine and then we will do a
political talk show do you guys love
drinking wine over the holiday season
wish you could find high quality
delicious wines at an affordable price
well I've got some great news for you
for 200 years a few small families deep
in the Andes Mountains have been making
a dark red wine unlike anything you've
ever tasted these wines are made in such
small quantities many wouldn't normally
make it to the U.S but the guy's over at
Bonner private wine partnership have
partnered with these families to bring
this never before imported wine to Wine
lovers in the U.S plus no Oak extracts
or dyes no excess sugar and none of the
fillers Mass Market wine industry uses
in the grocery store wine up until now
you'd have to travel thousands of miles
in a five hour hour drive on treacherous
dirt roads just to get your hands on a
single bottle but today I've arranged a
special access for my audience to be
among the first Americans to reserve
this rare supply of extreme altitude
wine visit
bonnerprivatewines.com Dave and you'll
get top quality extreme altitude wine
for a huge discount perfect for any
holiday meal with the family if you
order today you'll not only get a huge
discount and complimentary shipping
you'll also get a bonus bottle of small
batch limited production wine from their
exclusive seller that's four bottles for
the price of three these wines are small
batch and they'll go fast so act today
just go over to bonnerprivatewines.com
Dave and now back to me okay so although
we are in DC and we're talking to
important influential people some with
positive vision for America and you know
good ideas in that nature we thought
well let's start with the view anyway
right because they're still doing what
they do over there and if you want to
talk about misinformation and
disinformation and how that if you're a
lefty or a Democrat or a liberal you get
what I always call as Democrat privilege
that is the one privilege in the United
States that you can lie and cheat and
get everything wrong and you will get a
promotion and you will be put on
television and you'll get an award and
all that good stuff well here is sunny
Hosten at the view you guys know Sunny
hoston racist Sunny Huston who might
have gotten herself in a little election
trouble the other day because she also
said that she voted for her son so
there's a little confusion around that
she might have committed election fraud
but putting all that aside she just
completely made up on the show live on
air yesterday that the Republicans
somehow want to change the voting age in
the United States to 28. but I will say
this just like the Latina saved the
Senate young voters saved this country
and we need to really understand that we
are supposed to leave this world in a
better place than we found it when you
look at the youth voter turnout in the
2020 to midterms they delivered key wins
for the Democrats younger voters aged 18
to 29 which by the way now the
Republicans want to raise the voting to
age 28. younger voters were the only
voter Group by age to overwhelmingly
support Democrats in the midterms
okay so she completely made that up she
completely made that up there is no
mainstream Republican anywhere we did
all sorts of Googling and duck duck
going and other search stuff things and
we couldn't find anything on that
apparently there's a Libertarian
podcaster who randomly mentioned it he
just floated the idea out but she
completely made that up the audience
kind of gasps like oh no the Republicans
are coming for young people also you
know this idea of sort of young people
pitting young people against old people
the young people save the country the
young people save the country that's
really dangerous you know how many of us
really know ourselves and our thoughts
to in to completion or to the best of
our ability when say we're 18 to 25. do
you think you were at your best at 18 to
25 or do you think that as you get older
generally speaking if you've got your
head on straight you're going to get
better and more refined in your thinking
and understand more about the nature of
your humanity and what freedom is and
what I don't know maybe history has
taught us and what Generations before
fought for and things of that nature so
she's so excited that young people and
it does look like a decent amount of gen
Z did get out there and vote and they
did break Democrat that part is true but
they saved us because if those old mean
Republicans had just voted and we would
have turned more red
what what does she think would have
happened well she I guess she thinks
that Nazis would have taken over and
fascism would have been here and
everything else anyway not that they
ever corrected anything that happens on
The View but it is a news show to some
degree ABC News uh unsurprisingly did
not issue a correction I mean she just
made it up and this goes consistently
while I'm sort of connecting this to
misinformation uh this goes consistently
to what I always say about they can
launder the lies right so she puts that
out on television now now the clip of
that will go viral in sort of the the
Democrat blue circles and then a whole
bunch of people will suddenly believe
that Republicans want to change the age
the voting age to 28. that is
misinformation and disinformation but I
assure you it will not and actually in
my opinion should not be corrected by
big Tech ABC as a news organization
because she's doing hot topics on a show
that brings news to people could issue a
correction that would be something a
little bit different but to segue from
that Tulsi gabbard who as you guys know
former Democrat Tulsi gabbard she
endorsed a whole bunch of Republicans
and and campaigned with a whole bunch of
Republicans before this election it did
not turn out that well but I can tell
you
that I know Tulsi believes she did the
right thing and you don't always win
everything in politics uh well she's
still beating the drum on the issues
that she cares about one of the big ones
is Tech censorship so although the
candidates that she was backing did not
do that well her star to me is still on
the rise because she's still positioned
as sort of a center-right same person
ex-lib kind of thing so she was guest
hosting for Tucker Carlson last night
and she had a nice monologue when it
came to how Democrats work with big Tech
to actually subvert democracy
fortunately while in Bali today instead
of delivering a necessary message of
unity to all Americans President Biden
chose to attack half the country once
again implying that the only acceptable
Democratic outcome is a win for the
Democratic Party
let me start with a few words about the
recent elections held in the United
States
what we saw was the strength and
resilience of the American democracy and
we saw it in action
and the American people proved once
again that democracy is Who We Are
and there's a strong rejection of
election deniers at every level from
those seeking the lead to our states as
long as the Democratic Party in the
permanent Washington Elite are working
hand in hand with Google and Facebook
and as long as Google is allowed to
continue to use its Monopoly power to
skew public opinion in a certain
direction literally manipulating the
information that we as voters are
allowed to see then there is no
democracy
yeah she's kind of right on that and it
reminded me of the clip that we showed
you yesterday of Senator Marco Rubio
talking about how the chips are so
stacked against those of us that believe
in Freedom right I don't even want to
say conservatives those of us that
roughly believe in Freedom and that
America is a decent place you've got big
Tech against you you've got all the
corporate power against you you've got
the cultural hegemony against you the
fact that these elections are so close
and that Republicans don't do all this
early drop-off stuff in early voting and
all that right generally Republicans
tend to show up on Election Day and like
that paper trail oh I filled this thing
out I dropped it in myself they're going
to count it right then and there we're
going to have some transparency when it
comes to these elections Marco Rubio
what he was saying was the fact that all
of that stuff is against us and these
elections are close show you that
actually we do have the right ideas
that's really the same thing that Tulsi
is talking about there that in essence
with so much misinformation that is
promoted by democrats such as Sunny
Hosten right 28 year old voting that's
what the Republicans want even though
she completely made it up the fact that
we are able to keep these things as
close as we can shows you we've got
something good here and we just have to
figure out how to fight back better
whether that is building new tech we'll
talk a little bit more about that in a
little bit whether that is solidifying
these elections I mean the the 20-point
win by Ron DeSantis in Florida is not
simply a result of how good he has
governed it's that's a huge part of it
obviously but it's also largely in part
because we have secure elections here so
nobody except for the woman that sits
next to Sunny host and Anna Navarro who
lives in Florida nobody thinks that
there were any Shenanigans in the
Florida elections but a lot of people
think that there were Shenanigans in
other elections we're going to talk
about Arizona in just a minute and then
oh by the way I don't know if you've
heard about this but that that orange
guy Donald Trump he might be making a
big announcement tonight do I have that
bus can I get that bust back in here I'm
gonna when I do the Trump segment I want
to hold a trump a bust of Donald Trump
uh anyway we're going to talk about
Arizona in a sec let me talk to you guys
about bullying Max real quick uh you
know as inflation surpasses highs not
seen in 40 years the value of the dollar
is decreasing with every passing day
you're paying more at the pump at the
grocery store for cars and housing face
it paper money is worth less friends the
timing couldn't be any better for my
newest sponsor bullion Max bullion Max
is a direct to Consumer precious metal
retailer who can help you diversify into
gold and silver is a hedge against
inflation it's also security for your
family in times of crises and here's why
I love bullion max they're owned by
veterans in the precious metal space
offer some of the lowest prices on the
internet and they make it so easy to buy
directly from their website I want to
help you get started so I worked out a
special offer just for you get bullion
Max's silver starter kit is at employee
pricing just go to booleanmax.com Dave
the kit includes five of the most
desirable silver products to invest in
including a silver American eagle and a
silver Australian kangaroo this offer is
limited to just one per household so get
yours now go to bullionmax.com Dave now
and now back to me you know real quick
before I move on to what's going on in
Arizona I meant to tell you guys this
yesterday because it's just hilarious as
I'm walking here so you know we live in
Florida now
my whole team is with me and we don't
really see homeless encampments in
Florida we just don't see them we don't
have them in Miami area certainly and we
really don't have them in Florida but
anyways we're in DC so it's sort of like
being in La they've like basically tent
cities for homeless people so Daphne my
assistant and I were walking over to the
to the studio and I had and I'm holding
a hanger with my jacket and shirt and
everything so I didn't want to get all
all wrinkled and we have to go under a
bridge and there's literally like a
homeless huge homeless city under a
bridge I mean I'm talking dozens of
tents under there whatever we have to
walk past it it didn't look like the
safest place to walk through but we we
knew that to get to where we had to go
otherwise we're going to really circle
around anyway we start walking through
this guy comes out of a tent starts
coming right at us and so we kind of
like you know what are we gonna do and
uh he goes no no there he goes guys guys
don't worry I don't want any money from
you I just want your jacket and I was
like well
you you can't have my jacket but I
appreciate the honesty in the uh in the
sales pitch over there anyway little
little throwaway you know I forgot what
it's like to be in a largely blue area
where you know homeless people will
negotiate what they want out of you
anyway let's talk about uh Arizona for
just a sec so the gubernatorial race has
been decided at least for now uh Katie
Hobbs has won the Arizona governor race
over Carrie Lake you know one of the big
issues in Arizona that Kerry Lake was
constantly talking about Carrie Lake did
believe Donald Trump's accusations in
2020 she was talking about election
fraud the entire time so it almost seems
like this was the race that this was
going to happen in it's a it's a razor
thin uh margin and I suppose Kyrie lake
is going to get involved in some
lawsuits and a whole bunch of other
things but they're already the machine
is already spewing out misinformation
and disinformation about the Arizona
election itself and by the way as you
know today is Tuesday election day was
last Tuesday seven days ago so it took
them basically six and a half days to
count those last couple hundred thousand
votes does that give any let's say it
was all legit right I'm not even I'm not
even claiming there was fraud let's say
it was all legit does that give anyone
confidence whether you're in Arizona or
anywhere else just looking at Arizona
going well wait a minute why were they
able to count millions and millions of
votes and then suddenly these last
couple hundred thousand with the drop
boxes and the early voting and
everything else this took them six extra
days to figure out it all just stinks it
doesn't mean that you have the Smoking
Gun but it just doesn't feel right and
actually as I said to Tim Poole last
night I think some of the incompetence
is actually intentional it's not that
they're cheating outright but if you can
get enough people to believe that the
system doesn't kind of work then people
give up hope and you gotta have hope you
gotta have Hope anyway here is uh Andrea
Mitchell on MSNBC saying that Maricopa
County which is where some of the crazy
irregularities were there just the best
you got to trust these people over at
Maricopa and Mark let's talk about what
we've learned from for instance what's
happened out in Maricopa County what's
left out there in terms of how the vote
keeps you know coming in despite all of
what has been said by Donald Trump and
other election deniers and now beginning
to be also Kelly Ward who's falling
behind about uh you know Kitty Bob hubs
but the governor's phrase
Maricopa County has some of the best
vote counting processes because of past
problems yeah Andrea they have a whole
lot of practice
first off she doesn't sound very
confident as she's saying it but if
Maricopa County has some of the best
processes then why did it take them an
extra six days actually you want to know
about some of the best processes uh you
could try Miami which was formerly blue
right you could try uh Tallahassee you
could try Orlando you could try any of
the counties and the cities in Florida
where things were smooth and easy and
that's all because the Republicans went
out of the way DeSantis and Marco Rubio
went out of their way to secure
elections just make sure it's legit not
cheat but make sure IDs Paper Trails Etc
you get it so how is it possible why
would she even say that how would how
could you look your audience Andrea I'm
talking to you lady I do a similar thing
for a living right we're both talking to
the camera how can you look at the
camera Andrea and say to your audience
that they have some of the best
processes when it's six days after when
the election was supposed to be called
come on lady anyway here's Maricopa
County official Megan Gilbertson and she
is not instilling any confidence in
what's going on over there somebody's
gonna have to tell Andrea Mitchell about
the possibility that they're slow
rolling the vote we checked in with
those election officials about the
process why it's taking so long here's
what they told us
this is fast for Maricopa County it
usually takes us anywhere between 10 and
12 days to complete the count and we
think we're going to be done by the end
of this week
you know it's interesting how MSNBC
frames things so they bring this woman
in to say oh it took a long time but uh
you know it's still working and it's
pretty good but that's not evidence of
anything right that's not evidence that
it's good just because she says it's a
little faster than it would normally be
why is it still broken how about that
how about that so the takeaway from from
I would say last Tuesday specifically uh
and now what's happened with Arizona is
that a certain amount of people what
happened with Arizona and Pennsylvania
and certainly Michigan which you're
going to talk about in a sec is that the
Democrats did not pay for what I think a
lot of us thought they were going to pay
for I think a lot of us that are Freedom
loving that don't want to be injected
with [ __ ] and chop kids genitals off and
all that stuff we thought that more
people I suppose were like us now it
should be noted that the Republicans won
the popular vote in the midterms by
about 5 million votes they're still you
know they're still trying to figure out
the exact amount because we're a week
later and they're still accountable but
Republicans did get more votes
Republicans will get the house uh
Florida went solidly right as you know
New York picked up I think I think they
flipped four blue seats red so like some
good things did happen here
um but but broadly speaking the people
who locked everybody down and crushed
economies and all that stuff they did
not pay the price uh Gretchen Whitmer
you guys know it I've told you about her
many times she is one of the worst the
idea that this woman was re-elected uh
Tudor Dixon did a fine fine job I was
really impressed by her and I hope that
she has a bright political future in
front of her and if she doesn't want to
do politics she had a good career
beforehand then she'll be just fine but
Gretchen Whitmer was voted in again the
people they voted people in who were
locking them down and then not abiding
by their own lockdowns here's Whitmer
because now they launder the lies she
goes on CNN uh claiming that she won
because you know she's focused on the
right stuff keeping governor's office
but also control both Chambers in your
Michigan legislature first time that's
happened in almost 40 years what
takeaways do you have for National
Democrats about your win in Michigan
well I can tell you we stayed focused on
the fundamentals right whether it's
fixing the dam roads or making sure our
kids are getting back on track after an
incredible disruption in their learning
I mean it's just incredible it's just
incredible this woman kept kids out of
school for a year and a half almost into
two years in the debate as you know she
said she only did it for three months
she bold face lied I didn't see any
Washington Post Pinocchio lie check on
that thing the idea that people it's
it's unfathomable to me
it is it unfair yeah it's unfathomable
not in fathom it's unfathomable to me
that people said we want more of that
but that's what people in Michigan
decided to do uh she also said that the
Democrats ran on bodily autonomy which
is a little confusing to me because I'm
fairly certain they wanted to inject
people with vaccines that don't work
make people's lives better but also
protect our ability to make our own
decisions about our bodies these are
fundamental core issues if we're going
to design our lives and make our
decisions around our families that is
you know without question an economic
decision as well
that's interesting so the woman who was
forcing people out of jobs locking
people up at home now she was going out
and partying with her husband on their
boat during all the lockdowns and all
that stuff you guys know that the
hypocrisy knows no end
um she's suddenly interested in bodily
autonomy so when it was about abortion I
guess she's really into the idea that
you should be able to kill an
eight-month baby okay fine but when uh
it was about you making a decision hey
I'm 27 years old and I eat right and I'm
otherwise healthy and you know I'm a
little skeptical of things that just
appear out of nowhere and mRNA
technology and maybe I don't want to get
this vaccine and I take good care of
myself she was not for bodily autonomy
then right so the idea that they can
even say that with a straight face it is
just incredible as if they care about
freedom and then she links it to the
economy and it's like well lady you
destroyed the economy has she been to
Detroit lately you do not want to go to
Detroit people it's like downtown
Fallujah
Fallujah another guy who was just
absolutely terrible during covet this is
just a quick throwaway for you a tweet
from the New York Post uh let's do it
again New York's push for probe of
Cuomo's five million dollar covid-19
book deal you may remember that at the
height of kovid when everyone was saying
you know Andrew Cuomo he's going to be
Joe Biden's attorney general and he's
the hero of kovid and everything else he
ended up resigning in disgrace killed a
lot of old people by sending them back
into nursing homes and everything he
wrote right he wrote air quotes a book
on covid leadership in the middle of it
got a 5 million dollar advance that's
what I'm talking about the laundering of
the lies right you keep doing everything
wrong and you'll be rewarded handsomely
for it well now they're looking into it
and he may have to give that five
million dollars back ironically if he
was if he was the governor right now of
New York it'd probably be a little bit
better than hochul but uh hey you get
what you vote for uh all right let's
move on to uh other people in New York a
little bit from AOC because she is not
happy that Mandela Barnes lost his race
for Senate in Wisconsin to Ron Johnson
and you're not going to believe it guys
quick get you got to secure yourself in
your seat you know what she's blaming
this on
yeah racism I think there's argument to
be
important to identify ourselves strongly
as who we are I I think Tim Ryan ran a
phenomenal race Mandela Barnes ran a
great race I think there are racial
Dynamics in that race that need to be
discussed in terms of how Republicans
targeted a a black man running in that
race and I think that that needs to be
just put out there
man AOC you you are just such a clown I
I it is so unfortunate that she is still
part of this government you know what's
interesting there she says there she
talks about two races Tim Ryan so Tim
Ryan lost obviously to JD Vance in Ohio
and then uh Mandela Barnes who lost to
Ron Johnson in Wisconsin so she's upset
about these two losses
um Tim Ryan is white so obviously oh
well he's white I guess he just lost we
don't know exactly why but of course the
black guy Mandela Barnes has to lose
because of racism it's not because there
was all this crazy video of him talking
about releasing prisoners back into the
streets and defunding the police and
everything and the rest of his bad
Progressive ideas it can't have anything
to do with that it has to be because
he's black Tim Ryan will have to figure
it out there must have been some other
reason with Tim Ryan because he's white
he's got white privilege he was running
against another white guy whiteness
Rises to the top or something like that
and uh with uh with Mandela Barnes no
it's got to be racism and that is a
fundamental difference I would say
between uh blue and red which is that
when when Democrats lose they blame the
Republic Republicans and the base and
they blame America because America is
racist and bigoted and hates women and
all of that stuff right that's generally
what they go to exactly what AOC did
right there Republicans when they lose
and Republicans are sort of taking this
thing as a loss even though I said
Republicans going to get the house it
wasn't it's not a total loss and we'll
see what happens with the Senate
but you know what Republicans seem to be
doing Republicans really seem to be
going man which way do we have to go in
this thing do we have to think about
this different was a guy like Dr Oz a
real mistake because look we ended up
with fetterman so maybe we don't want
these Hollywood type people even though
someone like me kind of came around on
him but maybe that was a real mistake
there maybe if you take people like
Blake Masters again who I like and
Carrie Lake who I like that these were
people who were not in politics before
and you ran both of them uh in Arizona
maybe that was a mistake like
Republicans all and I can tell you this
from sitting here with Rand Paul and
with Jim Jordan and I'm going to
continue talking about it this week with
other Republicans are all kind of going
well what can we do a little bit
differently here do we have to go more
the Trump route is there more of a
DeSantis party like what what are the
policies that we have to have as opposed
to just being like no it's because the
the Democrats are all racists or all
socialists or whatever it's like what
can we do and that's I think how you
refine ideas and get better so that is a
bit of a silver lining to all of this
um anyway let's move on to Trump for a
moment and I have
a Donald Trump bust right here look at
this thing a bust of Donald Trump uh
Donald Trump apparently tonight they're
saying is going to announce well he's
saying he's making a major announcement
everyone is saying that that he's going
to run for president again which I can
only imagine the heads that will be
exploding and the peace and tolerance
rallies that we're going to be having
all throughout blue cities but who the
hell knows what he's going to do like I
think he could do anything at this point
like maybe he'll leave the party like
and start the Trump party the mag apart
like who knows what he's going to do but
anyway he's back in the news and
everyone's talking about Trump again and
they're talking about this you know
potential Trump and DeSantis thing uh
but let's relate this back to
misinformation which is where I started
here's MSNBC uh talking about why Trump
took things and brought them to
Mar-A-Lago even though that thing kind
of fizzled out didn't it saying that
federal agents and prosecutors as it
relates to the classified documents that
the former president had at Mar-A-Lago
that these agents and prosecutors have
come to believe that his motive was
largely his ego you write and a desire
to hold on to the materials as trophies
or mementos according to people familiar
with the matter I should also note that
you you point out that um this analysis
on the motive is not strictly speaking
an element of determining whether
anything he did was Criminal
I love what they're doing over there
first off I'm not sure your motive she
finally gets to it at the end I'm not
sure your motive if you did something
truly illegal your motive whether your
motive was good or not is sort of
irrelevant but you know it's his ego
that's why he took these documents
presidents every president who has ever
existed has taken documents from the
White House they figure out what they're
going to do with things and they have
archives and build libraries and all of
these things with trump it was his ego
that he had to do you know that's what
caused him to do all of this uh and uh I
guess the guy does have a bit of an ego
uh now we have to flip back to the view
geez why do we do this to the people and
in Navarro uh was talking about the the
big Trump wedding Tiffany uh Trump who's
Donald Trump's youngest daughter uh she
got married this weekend and Anna
Navarro was a little a little catty
about it Anthony's dress I couldn't pull
it off but that was beautiful Tiffany
looks fantastic they used to always come
down on her and she was the unattractive
Trump he was the one she was the Q Trump
she just married an actual billionaire
not one that had to Borrowed billions
from the Saudis you see maybe we'll see
his taxes
Tiffany's winning okay I think they I
think those Trump women look like a box
of jordan almonds
I'm not even sure what the joke is there
like our jordan almonds a special type
of almond that look a little more like
Trump people or they're a little paler
is that what the idea is I mean just try
to do the reverse of this right I know
you guys get it and the double standards
don't matter to some degree but if you
do the reverse of this imagine if this
was a group of Republican women talking
about aoc's wedding and she had a bunch
of Latina girls on stage with her and
they were like boy that reminds me of a
bunch of Junior Mints or something like
that right it's like
really like these people they're just so
boring and everything's racial to them
and not good I don't like these ladies
of the view I don't like you ladies uh
anyway it does appear Trump's doing
something tonight Trump posted this on
Truth social uh he said hopefully
tomorrow will turn out to be one of the
most important days in the history of
our country so we shall see what that
means uh again he did do that on Truth
social which is his you know Twitter
clone which I'm posting on Truth social
as well I think they're doing a nice job
over there but he is not on Twitter that
stuff remains to be seen how Elon will
deal with him Elon has said several
times that he's going to deal with all
of the banned people but they're trying
to figure out so many things at once
right now and it has definitely not been
an easy lift over there and the and the
main purpose uh or the main point of me
uh bringing up truth specifically is
that we still need Alternatives they are
not going to stop with misinformation
they are not going to stop looting with
the government to silence certain people
yes maybe Elon will have some force
fields around Twitter now but it'll
still be happening when it comes to
Facebook and Instagram and other things
so we must continue uh to build new
things and and find those off ramps uh
and here's just a little bit of me
discussing just that on Tim Poole's IRL
last night but I am telling you without
question there has never been a tech
company built in in any sense that we
know anything of that it is free speech
is baked into the ethos of this company
I'm telling you everyone on the board at
Rumble is in this thing for free speech
for every issue we've discussed here
these people are in it for the right
reasons it is not the perfect force
field
um for some of the reasons that you
mentioned but it's pretty damn good
Rumble also has a lawsuit right now
against Google that's gonna you know
that we won discovery on so Rumble is
going to get access basically to the
Google algorithm
so if you didn't know about that last
part that I mentioned uh Rumble about
two years ago sued Google over their
search and where they were depressing
certain views and hiding certain things
and elevating other things uh a judge I
think it's a California judge actually
went ahead and approved the the lawsuit
to go forward so Rumble is going to get
Discovery and within that can kind of
figure out what Google was doing with
the algorithm so Google may have to pay
out billions of dollars if they don't
want anyone to look at the algorithm the
point is that between Twitter and some
of these lawsuits and some of these
documents being leaked where we're
seeing the collusion with the government
some of the stuff some of the
misinformation that was told to us to be
true and nonsense it is kind of bubbling
up right now it we are getting some
clarity on some of this stuff and I
think that's really really good we still
have to keep building things we have to
build I mean when I say that it's like
we have to build better Tech but we have
to build better States we have to build
better institutions better educational
institutions better everything like we
can actually do it guys we really can
that's what the American dream is all
about like oh there's a problem let's
solve that problem maybe we'll make a
little money along the way too that
would be that would be pretty cool uh
all right we got a cold close for you in
just a moment let me get to a couple
comments from the Reuben report locals
Community uh EK says Whitmer looks like
the Green Goblin
no offense to the Green Goblin uh yeah
her it's her face it's like it looks
like a mask lady he's up with the botox
Elizabeth says Democrats can say
anything and the media will back them up
I wouldn't be surprised if they'd Go
full 1984 and write and back date an
article about it I mean yeah nothing
would surprise me at this point it is
just that is what it is but it's one of
those things where I think the best way
to not get frustrated by it is know it
you're watching this show you guys know
it right like you can see through the
nonsense to the best of your ability to
the best of my ability and then you you
won't go crazy when they lie you'll be
able to calmly do experience explain to
your friends you know that was a lie
right like that moment that I had with
Bill Maher Bill uh Hillary said that
Donald Trump's an illegitimate president
no no that's what he said no she didn't
I said bill I got the receipt now Bill
knows maybe that moved him a little bit
not enough for this election but like
being armed with the truth it'll keep
you calmer it'll keep you happier and
it'll keep you saneer uh Amy says why is
it that at a time when slow vote count
is happening in in the same places in
record numbers it never turns out to be
it never turns out to favor the
Republican candidate isn't that
something isn't that something it never
does like not uh occasionally not once
in a while it never does now the
Democrats would argue well that's
because our people like early voting
more are people like mail-in ballots
more now that may be true but it does
not mean that it's right this bundling
has to come to an end as I said earlier
even if it's all legit
I can't right now I can't sit here and
point to something that I know was an
absolute fraud but even if it's all
legit how do you think the average
person even even a Democrat now right
Mark Kelly will be the senator okay
Katie Hobbs will be the governor do you
think the average arizonan feels more or
less confident in their elections right
now even if they got the result that
they want they have to be going well why
did this thing take six days what are we
doing here and Andrea Mitchell can tell
you in the Maricopa County's got the
best election security and systems
around but the proof is it took them six
days so it's like
come on lady we can see some stuff right
in front of us uh guys we are going to
continue uh an exciting little trip here
in DC we're going to wander out I'm
going to go to the Washington Monument
we'll go to the Lincoln Memorial we're
going to go to the Jefferson Memorial
which is one of my favorites it's a
little bit off the beaten path we're
going to wander around I'm going to head
over to Newsmax a little bit later uh
and uh oh and then I'm going over to the
Senate building but that's on the deal
why did I say that well what am I doing
over here uh part one of my interview
with former Wisconsin governor Scott
Walker is up right now and uh you can
join us as always if you want to chat
along with us during the show at Ruben
report.locals.com and we leave you with
the elderly man pretending to be
president
thank you
[Music]
[Music]